something that we've been missing is
live entertainment on
fremont street in the city well that's
coming back too bianca holman is live
this afternoon with reaction from
visitors bianca
[Applause]
downtown is known for its unique eats
its boutique casinos and hotels
and live music on these six blocks right
behind me
now at the top of next month visitors
will have a full downtown las vegas
experience again
on june 1st at midnight friedman street
experience will activate all three
stages with free music
due to covet restrictions these stages
have been empty
they've sat empty for the past year we
spoke with locals and tourists and they
tell us they're excited about the return
of live music
because it'll bring more foot traffic to
small businesses and provide
opportunities for those in the music
industry to perform
well i've been here since this place was
not existent
of music and it was like once a year
like a big band would come so now it's
like
24 7. it's important i think it's
extremely important i'm glad it's going
to be open 100 percent
when it was covered we couldn't make no
money but now it's back
now we can make our money back again
and when it comes to coping 19
guidelines the fremont street experience
states on their website they will follow
the governor's declarations no word yet
on
who is set to perform that entertainment
list will come out
next week reporting from downtown bianca
holmen 8 news now